The COVID seems to be going around again. Have any must-have items that we need to keep around?
Well, if, to be honest, I'm not convinced that COVID could
was the cause of everybody's illness last time at quote-unquote wet-around.
The test for it is worthless. If you did the test and tested positive,
for you to think that you had COVID, even though the COVID test was positive,
you're mistaken. It doesn't mean you don't have it, but you have just as great or
probably an 80% chance that it was some other virus or some other bacteria that you contracted
and were dealing with. So that's a side note. What should you do for viruses or bacteria?
Are they creating worse viruses in the lab and creating them to be more viral and dangerous to humans?
Very ill and dangerous to humans. Yes, they are. Why are they doing that? That's really conspiratorial.
Well, yeah, it is, but it's true. So we can get into the conspiracies of why they're doing those
kind of things, but that's the truth. Those things are, there's different viruses and different bacteria
that we're going to be exposed to that are going to be virulent and could cause issues.
That's why you should have. That's where I would use Iverbectom. That's where I might use
Spend Medisinal. That's where I might use some medication like that. So keeping that in your
cupboard, having that in stock would be a wise thing to do. I think paracleric is another wise thing
to have in stock. Think methylene blue could be another wise thing to have in stock.
Now there's a company that we sell a lot of their products. I really like their products
called professional formulas. They sell a lot of, they're really up on this, and they sell a lot of
homeopaths for these things. You can get H1N1, H1N2 homeopathics. That's why the homeopaths.
So think about having some of those in stock. I mean, the shelf life on those is
really forever. So having to keep you that in your cupboard because those are going to like sell
instantly if another pandemic takes place. So having those in stock, having your cupboard
with some of those things can be beneficial. Now things like the stock expectancy,
the life expectancy of some nutrients like echinacea can diminish over time. So echinacea,
some herbals like that have a shelf life of maybe two, three years, four years.
Paracleric because it is not necessarily immune stimulant herbals. It can have a shelf life where
the herbals will typically just diminish their potency over time. So you might have to just take
more. Now other supplements like vitamin C and like our clear CV, like clear CV was created
basically for COVID, right? We call it clear CV for kind of a hidden name for because we can't say
COVID, but it's it's just to be in general immune stimulant, zinc,
echinocistide, vitamin C, a couple of other things in that vitamin A. So it's just a general
immune stimulant if you feel like you have a virus. So that's a good thing to keep on here. Now that
has an expiration date on it like everything legally has to have an expiration date on it, but
quite honestly, the expiration date with something different antioxidants like NAC in it,
it literally nearly inspires. So it's it's going to stay potent for, you know, a decade or two.
So having that on in stock and even in the back of your cupboard is good to have in case something
crazy goes on. Cheeto is probably going to happen in the next several months, something just
going to happen. So you just need to be as prepared and wise as possible without being crazy about it
or anything like that.